thank you uh yeah so
in this talk i will try to present you
first of all very simple proof of
three and lower bound and then for
general circuits and then i will
just give you an overview on how we
managed
to to push it just a little bit further
so just a reminder in this talk we will
consider
the general circuit model okay so
uh each gate computes any binary
operation
any of 16 possible binary operations fan
out of any gate is not bounded and depth
is also unbounded
sometimes it is convenient to consider a
circuit just as a very simple program
where each operation is just a binary
operation on inputs or previous
or previous operations
so yeah first of all of course we know
just by counting that a random function
requires exponential size circuits
however
this is what we know for explicit
functions and
the picture is quite depressive actually
so apparently the first level bound was
proved in 65 by close and malicious and
the function is the following so this is
just a product of
it's the sum of quadratic monomials then
in 74
schnorr proved the same lower bound but
for a just quite wide class of functions
one of them is mod 3 for example
in 77 paul proved
a lower bound 2.5 for a modification of
storage access function so
in this case x is a vector of n bits and
a and b
are vectors of log n bits so what you
output is just the corresponding bit of
x
i mean x sub a plus x sub b then in the
same year stuck meyer proved 2.5 and
lower bound for symmetric functions and
and in 84 so roughly 30 years ago
bloom improved the bound to 3 n
for the following function
actually for just for many symmetric
functions for example for mod
3 for mod 4 for majority so it works
for all mod functions and actually for
many symmetric functions
right so then some time ago we managed
to
uh to prove the same three and lower
bound it is actually not three
n but three and minus small of n but for
some complex functions called the fine
dispersers
and in this talk i will try to give you
the main ideas on how we managed to
improve this
a little bit so yes
they're actually tight some of them are
tight so
how many of them are tight right uh
so i believe that so for symmetric
functions
uh there is at least one symmetric
function namely mod 4
for which the complexity is 2.5 n for
this function for example
i only knows up about 6 n
so it is not tight right for this one
i just i have never said probably this
is not tight but
right uh so this is how it looks
like pictorially and this is
how our improvement looks like this so
not so impressive right so uh what i'm
also going to show you
is is a another small improvement which
which at least you can see on the
picture however this is for for
non-explicit function
and and this is probably the main point
of my talk so i i would be very happy if
one of you
could construct a function for which we
can prove this this lower bound
okay so all i mean almost all lower
bounds for
for unrestricted circuits are proved
by the so-called gate elimination method
whose idea is almost obvious so just to
prove a three and low amount you proceed
as follows you
say that you are going to make n
substitutions of
say variables by constants and you need
to show that each time you can
kill at least three gates so if you make
n substitutions and kill
three gates at least three gates at each
substitution then the initial circuit
contains
at least three and gates of course
right so let me show you how this can be
used to prove three and lower bond for a
fine dispersers
and before this let me present the
definition of
of this function so a boolean function
on
variables is called an affine dispersor
for dimension d
if it is not constant on any fine
subspace of
dimension at least d so
what an equivalent formulation is the
following if we have an affine disperser
we can make any n minus d linear
substitutions
before it will degenerate to a constant
right and this is this is an important
property for us
so what is what is nice is that uh
explicit constructions of affine
dispersers where d
is small of n often unknown since 2010
roughly and we we're just well the
construction is complicated i mean the
proof is complicated
that a particular function satisfies
this property but fortunately
we can use this function just as a black
box
okay so this is this is the lower bound
uh that we proved some time ago
let me just read it so if you have an
affine disperser for dimension d and you
have a circuit that computes this
function then what you can show is that
the number of gates plus the number of
inputs of this circuit is at least four
multiplied by n minus d well normally
of course if a circuit computes a
function on n variables then the number
of inputs of this circuit is equal to
n so for for the induction to go through
it will be convenient here to use
well to use more more than n inputs
and you will see this in a minute so let
me just show you
how this uh implies three and lower
bound for for an affine disperser
well you just plug you can see the
circuit that computes on a fine
disperser
for dimension small of n then s of c
is the size of circuits is the number of
gates
i of c is equal to m and here we have 4n
minus something small so we conclude
that the circuit complexity of an affine
disperser for some linear dimension
is and minus something small okay so
what was interesting uh what is
interesting also and this was
actually noticed by ryan is that
uh that this mount is tight uh
because the inner product function on n
variables
first of all it has circuit complexity n
minus one of course
well you you just compute it in a
straightforward way
and what is less obvious is that in a
product
is an affine disperser for dimension n
over two plus one
roughly n over two so if you plug it
well this will turn into
just equality up to some additive
constant
okay so now i'm going to show you just
probably
two slides to prove this result
uh the first thing that we need is to
transform
our circuit into so-called soar xor
layered circuit
for this we just take any any input of a
circuit that computes a linear function
for example in this picture this is this
gate and this gate
and we just replace it with a new input
so we assume that our circuit is given
for free
any any linear combination of input
variables okay so
what what is what is also important for
us is
that the sum of of the number of inputs
and the number of gates
is not changed under this transformation
okay now i need to show uh
that the number of inputs that the
number of gates plus the number of
inputs is at least
four multiplied by n minus d for this of
course i'm going to make just n minus
these substitutions
each time reducing this measure
by four and for this we just consider
two possible cases
so let's convert our circuit to xor
layer with second and take
the top gate namely the gate which is
fed by two
by two inputs and recall that in this
case inputs are
just a fine functions of of input
variables
right so there are basically two cases
either
both l1 and l2 has our degree two
without degree one
or for example l1 has our degree more
than one
so in this case we just assigned the
value zero to l1 this corresponds to
some linear substitution
in this case this gate becomes constant
so this constant is propagated to this
gate and these two gates are eliminated
moreover l2 is not needed anymore right
because it was only needed to compute
this
this
gate so we reduce the number of gates by
two
and the number of inputs by two so our
measure which is the number of gates
plus the number of inputs
is reduced by four in this case we do
actually the same we
we just substitute l1 by zero
this makes this constant this gate a
constant
this constant is propagated here so this
gate is also eliminated and this one is
eliminated
so once again we remove three gates and
at least one input
okay so this is basically the wall proof
of history and lower bound
yes now let me show you some of the
ideas
on how this analysis can be improved
so first of all this is like the the
exact
lower bounds that we get it is not three
zero one it is actually three plus one
divided by
eighty six that will try to to to give
you some intuition on where does this
constant
come from and this in particular allows
me not to
to put this small offend when i when i
state this lower bound is 3o
301 n okay so these are
these three probably main ingredients of
of our proof
first of all uh we are going to make not
only linear substitutions like
for example substitute x3 by 0 or x5 by
sum of other vari variables but we are
also going to make
the so-called quadratic substitutions so
x3
we replace x3 by the product of x4 and
x7
so sometimes such substitutions helps us
to remove more than three gates however
of course we
then need a function that survives under
such substitutions but we still
we still use an affine disperser however
and each
such quadratic substitution for each
such quadratic substitution we promise
that sometime in the future we will
substitute x4
or x7 by a constant this will make this
quadratic substitution a linear
substitution
the next thing is that uh well for some
technical reasons we need to generalize
the model we can see the circuits some
weird sync
circuits with cycles i will explain in a
minute what does it mean so
surprisingly for me such circuits were
actually already studied
even 20 or 30 years ago even by rivest
the last ingredient is that instead of
just using the number of gates plus a
number of inputs we use a very carefully
selected complexity measure i will show
you
the the exact formula so first of all
let me show you what does cyclic
circuits mean so this is
some strange circuit so you can see that
there is a cycle
in this circuit and there is another
cycle actually so it is not even clear
how to start
the computation in this case right
however this is a reasonable model
so it computes this program
at this time it is not already a program
it can be considered
just as a as a set of
of equations right on g1 and so on g5
so we can write for example it as
follows
so this this program computed by this
circuit can be written as a
as a set of linear equations right
then we can just well in this particular
case
this matrix has a full rank so we can
solve it
and what we get is just the following
five
linear functions so these are the
functions computed by this
circuit and sometimes such cyclic
circuits are
more powerful than normal non-cyclic
circuits
so but this is this is just an
interesting model but we need it because
of some technical reasons
just for for our induction to go through
okay so
this is the measure that we use to
estimate
the progress of our gate elimination so
s is
as in the previous lower bound is the
number of gates
then we have the number of quadratic
substitutions
then the number of bottleneck gadgets in
in a given circuit and finally the
number of inputs
so these coefficients actually come
from from solving some linear program
that in turn comes from
from a long case analysis on what we can
eliminate
in in different cases
and so it is probably worth to mention
that
uh such complexity measures are actually
widely used
in estimating the running time of of
branching algorithms for np-hard
problems
so the approach is the general approach
is
you is called measure and conquer
okay so now finally
let me just show you probably without
providing any details
just the the statement of
a conditional 3.1 and lower bound
so the third
theorem is the following so if we manage
to construct a function
with the following property we can prove
is 3.1 n
lower bound and actually for
for this lower bound we fortunately do
not need
all this stuff with weird complexity
measures and cyclic circuits and so on
so the functions that we need i actually
present it
at the open problem session but let me
let me repeat it once again
because this is this is important for me
so
we need a function and then an explicit
construction of a function on n
variables
which is not a constant on any
subset s which can be defined as a set
of roots of polynomials say 2n
polynomials
where the degree of each polynomial
is at most 2 and this this set
is not is not very small so if we
and actually this is so what is known in
the field of extracting randomness is
actually
is actually close to what we need but
not but not exactly
okay so so they have constructions for
for fields of larger size and if i'm not
mistaken there are constructions
which work for for field with two
elements however
the the requirement on the size of the
set s
is not 2 to the n over 100 by
2 to the n over 2.
something like this so so this is
an open problem so we need an explicit
construction of such function it would
be interesting to construct
such a function even in np and even even
a function with
some small number of outputs for example
i mean
the problem is that i mean not the
problem but the state of the art is
is as follows we don't even need we
don't even know
stronger than three and lower bounds if
we allow a function to have
small off and outputs so you can prove
for example foreign lower bound for a
function which have
n outputs but if it has only small off
and outputs we do not know
anything stronger than for the case of
boolean predicates
yes thank you
maybe one quick question while igor sets
up
so that was the original attack of
the valley and to prove a non-linear
loving violence
and by embedding super translators
right and then it turned out that
they have enough size but still
unfortunately i haven't yet
read the corresponding paper thank you i
do remember andy
brooker asked me about the same thing
actually and that i completely forgot
unfortunately
so so the answer is that i just don't
know it is not excluded but
i do not know
uh so you just to be sure what you said
at the end
so you very very sad you said there's a
construction of
this quarter these versus this constant
100 is replaced by one half
yeah then the problem is that we will
only be able to make like 10 of the two
substitutions
instead of and this will only give us
some very weak load
something like 2m
so let's thank sasha